So today's the chemistry Nobel prize has been announced.
And for once it's really excited Neil,
because it's for lithium batteries.
And so he's gone on a battery Safari.
Some of you know that Neil is a motorcyclist.
He has an electric motorcycle,
which in the owner of the Nobel prize, he brought into the land.
How did you find out that they won the prize? Well,
I had planned to watch it live,
but I was actually working this morning and I forgot about the announcement.
So somebody came into my office, very excitedly, uh,
telling me the finally the lithium-ion people had got the prize.
It's been awarded to the people who really made lithium-ion batteries,
what they are today and gave us the kind of devices we,
we all take for granted.
The batteries on this motorbike are lithium ion
batteries, but they're not what they seem.
If you look inside them. And Neil started in the excitement,
taking it to bits to show us what's inside.
You'll find there is a whole stack of many,
many lithium ion batteries.
And the key point about these batteries is that they are small.
They have a lot of energy in them, and they're very light.
The reason they're lots of batteries is because each battery is
about four volts.
And to drive a motorcycle engine with enough power,
you need a much higher voltage.
So you will have a whole series of batteries in series.
This is much more efficient than low voltage,
where you need very thick wires to take the big current.
The way a battery works is effectively.
It shuttles electrons from a negative electrode to a positive
electrode in the batteries that were developed by the prize winners.
You have lithium atoms that release electrons and those electrons
travel through a wire power powering our phone or whatever it is.
And at the same time,
the lithium ions that are released travel through an electrolyte and then
recombine with the electrons. At the other side.
Neil decided he would try and find a lithium battery,
which he could take to bits. The first battery had found,
had lithium written on it,
but it was an old fashioned battery,
which not using modern lithium iron technology.
It said lithium [inaudible] chloride.
None of us actually know how it works,
except it's not the right sort as he was sewing it open.
He got really quite a nasty whip of some gas, probably the time chloride,
but this didn't stop Neil taking it to bits and throwing it into water.
Stanley was looking up materials that could, as we say, intercalate the lithium.
So when lithium travels through the electrolyte during the,
the battery operation, it intercalate into the positive electrode.
So he was developing materials that could capture this lithium after it was
released and then rerelease it. When we recharge the battery,
what happened subsequently was that good enough found a
material that was better at reversibly catching this lithium
and releasing it. The early batteries contained lithium metal,
which is very highly reactive.
So one of the developments that then came later on,
which is really the kind of third part of the prize,
if you like is that we realized that we could use
graphite to actually house lithium when the batteries fully charged.
So rather than use a piece of lithium,
which gets oxidized or releases its electrons,
we use graphite in which the,
the lithium is stored and that kind of stabilizes the lithium atoms.
So finally in desperation,
Neil offered to sacrifice one of the spare batteries from his mobile phone.
The phone only costs Neil five pounds.
That's about $6 and it had five pounds of free calls on it.
So it was a pretty good bargain. And when he started opening the battery,
he cut it in half and using a knife.
He short-circuited the two electrodes and you can see
the sparks, which show the amount of energy that must be in there.
He then started unwrapping it and they think this particular battery is quite
complicated.
It will have obviously the material for both the cathode,
that's the positive electrode and the anode, the negative one,
but none of us could work out exactly what it was.
Neil had wrecked it, pulling it apart, but some of them fixed,
which suggested possibly that there was some lithium there,
but it might just have been electrolysis of the water.
We've been following the Nobel prize for many years now.
How do you feel about this one?
This seems like a good chemistry when this time doesn't it?
I think it's really good. First of all, it's chemistry. Secondly,
it really fulfills.
Nobel's original will that the price should be for something
that is really useful to humanity, energy,
efficient batteries, batteries that delight and store.
A lot of energy are really important for decarbonizing
our life, allowing us to use energy,
but without discharging so much CO2 into the atmosphere.
One of the things that this prize might do is, um,
in the wider community or in the public is perhaps get people excited
about batteries.
And then we can tell people about the new of batteries chemistries that are
coming along.
One of the things that we're working on at the minute is trying to move
towards what we call beyond lithium iron.
So this is the next generation of batteries.
These are the ones that will store much more energy than a lithium-ion battery
could be more potentially. Yeah. Yeah. I might still be in one a chance.
And then he plunged the burning lithium into the beaker.
I've got this and this is a real Nobel prize
metal.